nots can be used for many different
things to tie around the vessel to seal
it to join two structures together and
depending on the type of suture that
you're using each suture is going to
have anywhere between three to four up
to six or seven knots in it and well
part of our training is to know what
type of suture that is and and how many
knots it requires to have a good strong
holding ability but the basic principle
of knot tying is something that we've
we've learned since we were medical
students interested in surgery so when
you see a medical student over in the
corner just learning this we're putting
all of this pattern so that we don't
even have to think about how our time
there's so many different ways you can
tie your knot one way is what we call a
square knot this comes down as a perfect
circle that would be considered a square
knot and that's one of the most durable
knots if you pull it here then you can
convert it into something that you can
slip down so when you see people
practicing these in the background we're
having our brain laid that that
circuitry down to our hands too we
automatically are saying I want this
type of knot and we just able to perform
it as a surgeon and particularly as one
that's dealing with delicate tissues and
babies it's never perfect you strive for
that but you never stop practicing